how are you i'm good how are you good
thanks
lucy come here oh let me see you got
your dog i feel like i need to have my
dog we'll do the meeting i've got
two here we've got the baby oh
and then oh look at yours so this is our
baby
so cute our new one he's five months old
he's so snuggly oh the sun is yours
how's it going
good good are you i'm good okay really
not now that's not okay um
first of all i mean congratulations on
the show it's so incredible
where did this idea for the show come
like was it
because of your three dogs or where did
it come from um well renegade actually
had the idea for the show
and you know thankfully they thought of
me
i mean obviously i'm a huge dog lover
i've i've traveled with lucy for many
years and i've adopted two others so
they knew my love for dogs was strong
but
they you know mentioned the idea to me
it was perfect timing in the sense that
i was just finishing my skiing career
and i needed a new challenge and
yes what better adventure than to do a
show with my
with my dog lucy and 12 other dogs
oh that's amazing well i definitely
think the hardest part about your job
was the elimination
um i wouldn't be able to leave without
all the emotion how did you prepare for
that
it was hard i mean i i didn't really
know what to expect obviously going
in but you develop relationships with
with the cast and with the dogs
obviously and
and the elimination was really difficult
you know because
everyone they had built this incredible
bond
you know obviously the dogs but the
humans as well and
and you never wanted to see a cast
member leave you know they were always
crying and it was these long embraces
and
and it but it really shows you like the
love and humanity that we have
it's not a traditional you know
competition show it's really about
um lifting people up and that positive
spirit is
it's incredible i think yeah and really
but the back story of how incredible
these people are and the relationship
they
they have with their pet which i think
so many people can certainly relate to
especially now when we're at home so
much
100 i mean i don't know how i would have
gotten through the whole lockdown
without my dogs you know they
they're what keep me positive every
single day you know no matter what
happens
i know that they're gonna love me and
every morning
you know they lick my face and it's like
this day is gonna be great
so you know i i think i hope that people
adopt dogs you know
after this time i think that's something
that's happening a lot more often but
also that the show
you know shows everyone how amazing dogs
are and and how
strong and important that relationship
with dogs and humans is
yeah speaking of relationships with with
humans
um yours with pk the wedding is on hold
but i wonder is lucy or was lucy going
to be a ring bearer and what was the
plan there
i mean that's kind of my hope we don't
have really a plan because
we don't even have a plan for a wedding
right now but
um i'm hoping lucy and the other two
dogs can have a
part in our wedding in some way you know
maybe lucy can be the ring bearer or you
know they're walking down the aisle with
me i'm not sure how
we want to play they'll be a part of the
wedding for sure
i love that so is pk a good dog dad
yes he's a great dog dad i mean he like
loves feeding them and he has like
all the stuff on instagram where it's
like the dog food wars and
you know it's like he just always has
fun with them he always makes it playful
and
he definitely has a soft spot for lucy i
get jealous sometimes because lucy i
think looks
like snuggling with him more than me
that definitely hurts my feelings but um
you know he never grew up with dogs
so i'm happy that he loves mine like
they're his own
you